[Music]
it's really important for managers to
model the kind of openness that they
want to foster in their employees
because if you're working for someone
and they hide everything about their
Parenthood in the workplace you think
that that's the ideal and you don't feel
welcomed to share it yourself
but we all know that people who feel
like whole human beings at work bring so
much of their personal lives to work in
a way that ultimately fuels the work
that they do that makes them more
committed more dedicated and to be fair
a lot of these managers are from
potentially a generation before even two
generations before these current workers
who are primarily Millennials and they
may have had they're sort of a
self-selected group so in order for a
female partner at a law firm to have
made partner and now be the boss she is
one of their survivors so she's not one
of the 45% of the class that came in
female she is one of the 13 or 14
percent of female partners right so
something something happened to there
she had either more support from her
peers her bosses maybe she has a spouse
who's home with her kids whatever it is
she had something special that made it
work for her and sometimes it can be
hard for a manager in that position to
not expect the people underneath her to
be able to thrive in that same situation
you feel like oh well I I pledged
parenthood you should have to pledge
Parenthood too it's a very natural
instinct and I don't really blame people
for it however what we see everything we
know about millennial workers who are
going to be 75 percent of the workforce
by the year 2025 so like it's happening
is that they expect to bring their their
whole lives to work and if you can't
manage around that and you can't imagine
what that is like you're gonna be
outdated really really quickly as is
your company so the policies that are
going to be most effective in helping
you retain new parents and support them
and grow your company and grow your
industry are those that are completely
Untied to gender that are fair for
everyone that don't even label a couple
of years ago there was sort of this this
trend toward primary parents secondary
parent until everybody realized oh gosh
well that tends to divide along gender
lines first of all and secondly isn't
what we want actually an even balance or
at least you know the right for parents
to make that decision and decide for
themselves how they want to split it
down it also any mothers who were
breastfeeding I think kind of
automatically felt like they had to be
the primary parent and then the
secondary ended up being dad and then
dad didn't take as much leave anyway so
first and foremost it's about having the
same amount of leave for adoptive
parents same-sex parents moms dads
across the board let individual families
make their own decisions about what
works in their home and in terms of
their income because if you have dads in
the workplace saying I'm taking less
leave what they're really saying is my
salary is more important my work in the
workplace counts more and is worth more
money and that's a perpetuating problem
that ultimately impacts women's paycheck
and contributes to the motherhood
penalty furthermore so this book was
really the idea for the fifth trimester
was born out of the idea that yes six
paid months is is an ideal we do not
have that in our country right now and
if you are expecting a baby
you just need someone to tell you how to
do it in the mean time with the hope
that you go back to work and you can
either move up the ladder and change
actual policies from within your
workplace using the tools that are given
by these hundreds of women in the book
or simply by being transparent about
Parenthood in the workplace because if
we all sort of go one little tiny step
beyond what we're comfortable with in
our workplaces that one step is never
going to get you fired but if we all did
it universally together we would have
real dramatic cultural impact on what
people think of new Parenthood's in the
workplace so one thing that managers can
do is they can really be supportive of
new parents talking about their kids in
the workplace they can themselves
demonstrate if they have you know older
children or grown children or even an
aging parent who needs
haier be open about that personal life
need in the workplace say that you're
leaving because you are going to coach
Little League or whatever it is you're
or you're going to the doctor whatever
it is be open about that because I
guarantee you you also expect your
employees to be on email at ten o'clock
at night or you know to check their
phone first thing in the morning
so these you know these things kind of
come hand in hand so it is also about
acknowledging that in the United States
employees are generally back at work
before they're physically and
emotionally ready to be there being
sensitive to that and then really
tending to their phase back one really
really useful thing that's been shown to
work internationally in terms of
retaining women is to offer a phase back
program that is full pay for even as
little as a month or six weeks but you
have someone working a three-day week
that little bit of extra time helps
tremendously if new parents have a
grandparent close by or if I said
earlier if dad is able to take
intermittent leave offer intermittent
leave if you are an employer that sort
of extends the time that it lets baby
get a little bit older before babies in
somebody else's care and a little bit
less vulnerable and potentially
healthier so there are all kinds of
things that you can do if you can't
necessarily give six months of paid
leave to your employees you can do a lot
to manage that gap between when they're
coming back and when that six or seven
months would be up and just be sensitive
to that transition time and know that it
ultimately can set people up for long
term satisfaction if it's handled well
[Music]